ja hallo mein name ist evotec man als
königstein
ich bin landtagsabgeordneter im
sächsischen landtag als im wahlkreis
sächsische schweiz darauf die
die hochburg der afg liegt ganz im osten
der republik im bundestagswahlkreis
sächsische schweiz osterzgebirge hat die
partei vor vier jahren 35 5 prozent der
zweitstimmen erhalten
bei den erststimmen war es noch
deutlicher 37,4 prozent gingen an frauke
petry die einen tag nach der wahl aus
der fraktion aus trat
wie ist die afg hier verankert
die schweiz ist dass wir uns immer
darauf die die aussage von mir kennen in
der ard ich würde sagen sehr sehr viele
und ich habe auch ein grund dass
sozusagen
wir haben bei der europawahl wenn sie
wenn sie mal zurückschauen
deutschlandweit das beste wahlergebnis
erreicht
bei der bundestagswahl bei der
landtagswahl super wahlergebnisse
erreicht
die ard ist hier zu hause ich bin hier
zuhause ich bin teil der afd
also man fühlt sich einfach wohl dass
ihr die tiere passen die die politischen
einstellungen das ist politischer heimat
wenn sie wissen wie ich das meine
warum ist die fdp so stark die
entscheidende ist halt auch ein größeres
maß an unzufriedenheit und zufriedenheit
in vielen politikfeldern ganz klar
bundespolitisch landtagswahlen da wirkt
natürlich die bundespolitik immer mit
rein aber immer auch die landespolitik
und sie wissen selber 19 was da
historisch sagen alles dafür ereignisse
gelegen haben
ob das die eu politik die finanzpolitik
also fiskalpolitik betraf die
einwanderungspolitik die da sage ich das
gleich vorweg ich habe nichts gegen eine
einwanderung nach kanadischem vorbild
also eine kontrollierte fachkräfte
einwanderung die schadet uns nicht es
schadet uns aber eine unkontrollierte
einwanderung in die sozialsysteme das
kann kein land auf dauer verkraften in
größenordnung was bedeutet für sie
heimat
also heimat auf den punkt gebracht ist
verwischt die sächsische schweiz absolut
also mit ihrer fantastischen
naturausstattung heimat sind für mich
die menschen meine nachbarn meine
freunde auch die politische heimat sage
ich jetzt mal das war so gleich klingen
soll ich mal heimat ist auch gleiche
sprache und gleiche kultur ja also das
sind ganzes sind auch viele kulturellen
werte ja letztendlich weil ich mir doch
hier wohl fühle
wie ticken die menschen hier
es gibt den schönen spruch den finish
hoch ins treffen die sachsen sind helle
so und sie sind politik interessiert
also gerade hier und der sächsischen
schweiz wäre ich gerne nimmt das mir
gefällt da so richtig muss ich sagen
dass die leute nie hinterm berg halten
also die sprechen mich konkret an
was sind auf der seele drückt die auch
unbequeme dinge also es wird nie hinterm
berg gehalten es wird sehr direkt also
jedenfalls erlebe ich das so sie hat
direkt kommuniziert ich sag mal so die
klaren ansagen das ist das was mir
gefällt also das sind 10 kinder
drückeberger
wie würden sie sich selbst beschreiben
jetzt sagt man nach so der kämmerer zu
sein der unbequeme das bin ich an der
stelle auch gern also wenn ich an diese
zeit und denke die damals die
überschrift gebracht hat war der
kandidatenvorstellung der unbequeme dann
war das für mich jetzt kein schimpfwort
das war einfach gut gut zusammengefasst
man muss auch in der politik unbequem
sein um das zu erreichen
jetzt haben sie sich sehr viele hier
eingerichtet schwarzer pilze in sachsen
wir haben also viele strukturen die
einfach mal auch aufgebrochen werden
müssen damit wieder demokratie lebendig
wird